我が社員から見て自己実現の舞台なのかどうかっていうことですよ。当たり前のことに感謝できない経営者っていうのはなじゃないんだよ。社員のおかげで社長は成長するんです。青木サ市の人生警額
100回聞いたら豊かになる話。
今回はですね、従業員エンゲージメントを高めることが大切とよく言われると思うんですけれども、企業との深い繋がりを感じて会社のことを自分ごとできる人と自分ごとかできない人の違いってありますでしょうか?
うん。それは何?社員の立場っていうか社員の中に自分事として考えれる社員がいる。
そうですね。はい。
いるかないか。
そしてどうしたら自分事として考えられる社員を育てることができますかっていう質問でいい。
そうですね。はい。
うん。
経営者自身がまず社員にとって会社が自己実現の舞台かどうかで自分で自己評価してみたらいいと思う。
僕も今までね、9000人経営者の教育
担当してきたんだけど、ぶっちゃけたこと
言うと経営者はね、利己的なやつが多い。
社員をね、使ってやってるとかね、雇用し
てやってるとか立ち位置がね、偉そうなん
ですよ。まずもうこれああ、勘違いなのよ
。働いてくださってありがとう。うちの
会社を選んでくれてありがとう。
そういうまず心のあり方の問題なんだ、
これ。だ、これね、同じことはね、結婚
生活も言えるわけ。詳しくやってるとか、
俺が詳しくやってるみたいなね。お前なん
だ?専業主婦で何やってんだとか。なんで
あんたのためにね、選択してね、お散丼
やってね、誰のおかげで生きてんの思っ
てって、奥さんだってそういう主張あるよ
。で、あれ家事なんかね、実際の専業主婦
の人もしね、給料で計算したらめっちゃ
すごい報酬になるっていうデータがあるん
だから、それは結構社長よりも高い報酬
もらわなきゃいけないかもしんないで、
そりはそうでしょう。朝早くから起きて夜
遅くまで子育てなんかしてたら2人も3人
も育てながら中小企業の経営者の奥さん
なんかは会社の仕事まで手伝って
すごい労働じゃないですか。でもそのこと
に感謝できていない経営者めちゃ多いわけ
。いい?これポイントなのよ。当たり前の
ことに感謝できない経営者っていうのは
ろな経営者じゃないんだよ。ぶっちゃけた
こと言うと感謝なんですよ。僕なんか僕を
選んでくれた配偶者に対してプライドで
解消持ちとして僕を選んでよかったと絶対
言ってもらえるように頑張ろうって頑張り
ましたよ。子供が生まれてきたら父親の
学校歴のないことを家柄のないことで片身
の狭い思いさせないように一生懸命
頑張ろう。として子供から見て本当にこの
両親の元で生まれてきてよかったと言って
もらえるようなそんな親になろうと思って
頑張ったよ。すんごい教育投資もしました
よ。で、一生懸命ま、おかげ様で2人とも
良いね、人間に育ってくれました。今時さ
、なんかこう結婚ってコスパが合わないと
か子供作るのはコスパが合わないっていう
若い子もいるらしいんだけどこれ根本的に
間違ってんだよ。子育てによって人格が
磨かれるんです。こ同じロジックなの?
これ社員のおかげで社長は成長するんです
。社員に喜んでもらいたいという同機の
純粋性、社員を幸せにしたいという思い、
それが内発的同期付けを起こさせるんです
よ。で、そういう心を持って社員と接して
いくと、社員の中にこの組織に属してる
喜びだとか、一緒にこの理想を追求してる
喜びだとかみんなで共にだよね。共に
みんなで社会をよりよくしていく。良い
社会を作ってるという喜びだとかお金では
買えない喜びというものが実は生まれるん
ですよ。まず個人なんだな。個人の人間力
というか物の考え方が大事なのよ。まずだ
社長である前に1人の個人としてどういう
人なのかなのよ。その人が。で、その人が
会社を経営するわけだからその時に社員を
幸せにしたい。さっきは、ま、子供を幸せ
にしたい、家族を幸せしたい。全部繋がっ
てんですよ。これで社員をもっと物信とも
に豊かにしたい。そうするといい商品し
なきゃいけない。良い営業マーケティング
の仕組み作んなきゃいけない。良い人材の
採用と育成しなきゃいけない。財務戦略も
しっかりとダム経しなきゃいけない。新規
事業ももっと世の中のためになることを
この根感となる事業から枝派を広げて
もっと会社のね5年10年20年将来を見
てこういう新規事業もそこに進水しなきゃ
いけないとかいろんなもん出てくるわけで
うちもね嬉しかった報告があって今回
カンボジアでね正式にね死者のね認定を
カンボジア政府からもらいましたよ。でも
これだって今うちの会社のことだけ考え
たらわざわざ何も今カンボジアに展開する
必要ないわけだよね。でもこれもやっぱり
この4年間カンボジアから毎年3名ね、2
名3名の学生を採用してきて4年契約だ
から4年経った時にカンボジアに戻して
あげるとその時に祖国に貢献できるね人材
を育てたいもその受け皿である法人を用意
してあげてそうすると転職しなくて済む
じゃん。で、そこに一生懸命カンボジアの
ためにも力だ。カンボジアには学校3つ
作ってきたけど、その学校を作るだけじゃ
なくて、あのポルポト政権の中で傷ついた
人たちの少しでも力になってあげられる
ようにな、何ていうのかな。やっぱりそう
いう気持ち分かるかな、これ。そうすると
ね、これがね、カンボジアの子でもね、
言葉通じないでしょ。でもちゃんと伝わる
のよ。ちゃんとね、離職も少なく
一緒になってね、心志しを遂げるために
うちのこの理念ビジョンを共有して全く
文化違うところで育った人たちが一致団結
で頑張ってくれてる。だエンゲージメント
めっちゃ高いわけよ。全ては心の要素あり
方じゃないかと思うよ。そしてあとは精神
論だけじゃなくて具体的に経済的に豊かに
できる人事制度を作ったりやっぱり経営の
技術なんですよ。そこはもう極めていくよ
ね。徹底的に基準高く。うん。でも僕は今
ね、ちょっと精神論的なこと言ってるけど
めっちゃ厳しい経営者ですからね。約束を
守ること。指示したことは必ず報告連絡
相談ね。高連命令実施報告きちきちっと
やらないと気が済まない性格だし幻格です
よね。でもそういう中で起立やっぱりこう
社員が当たり前ということの当たり前が
変わってみんなの当たり前の基準が上がる
から相互信頼が生まれて良い組織文化の中
で人が育っていくわけですよ。こういう
ことがやっぱりまさに社員
エンゲージメントを高めることにもつがる
んじゃないの。ま、おかげ様でね、うち
もグレイトプレイストtoトワークで
グランプリを取りました。150カ国の
展開するね、この世界的な調査機関の
まさにこのグレイトプレスワークで日本の
中規模部門で100名から999名の規模
の中でグランプリありがたいことですよね
。ま、うちで学んでる受もみんないいしね
、いい成績を納めてくれてる人多いけれど
、やっぱりそれはね、社員に対するね、な
んだろう、感謝とかやっぱあり方が変わる
んですよ。こな間だもね、結婚式でね、
面白いメッセージしたんだけどね、
ちょうどその受行生の結婚式だったんで、
僕メッセージしたのは皆さんうちの研修を
受ける前皆さん人生の目的はって聞かれ
たら
勝つことですと皆さん答えませんでしたか
?うちの研修受けた後人生の目的はと聞か
れたら幸せになることだ。皆さん答えられ
たと思うんです。でもこの幸せというのは
人と共につまり共に勝つこの共にという
価値観みんなで共に良くなろうというそう
いう価値観の中で企業文化も良くなり家庭
も良くなりみんなやっぱり幸せになりまし
たよねっていうメッセージを結婚式でした
んだけど今の学校教育でもね勝つという
ことに焦点あってるだこの勝ということを
みんな関心があるんですよ。リーダーシッ
プっていうのはウィナーになるね。勝つ。
でも私は、ま、勝ち続けてきた人生だけど
実は僕は人を任そうと思ったこと1回も
ないんです。自分の理想に対してベストを
尽くしていったら周りがついてこれなかっ
ただけなんだよ。で、これが健全な姿だと
思うの。みんなが理想を目指していって人
と比較することなく自分なりのベストを
尽くしていったらいい人生をんじゃないか
なと。だ、うちの会社って社員同士競そわ
せないよね。ノルマもないし。だから社員
エンゲージメントがすごく高くなるんだと
思う。ま、そんな感じかな。
社員の目線でものを考えて社員の立場に
立って考えた時に
我が社は社員から見て自己実現の舞台なの
かどうかってことですよ。ここに関係性が
生まれるわけよ。会社で自己実現できない
から仕事さっさと済ませて個人で自己実現
いろんな遊び手しようとかそうなっちゃう
んだよ。だから会社はあくまでも生活の糧
を得るための手段としかならないから転職
もするし仕事そのものに生きがいを見出せ
ない。私は働き買いやりがい、究極
生きがいを感じてもらえるような職場を
作ることが大切だと思ってそこに取り組ん
できました。ま、是非参考にして
いただければありがたいなと思います。ま
、ちょっとね、手厳しいことをね、口が
悪いんですいません。行ったかもしれませ
んけれども、是非ね、頑張ってください。
ま、私もね、社員5名、資本金500万で
会社作って、ここまでね、決してね、準風
満パで来たわけじゃないんですよ。
いっぱい人にもやめられてボディブローを
食らい続け、それでも反省してどうしたら
もっといい会社ができるんだろうかと思っ
てチャレンジをしながらね、やっぱり振ら
れるのは辛いので振られなくてもいい会社
をどうしたら作れるかと、ま、今も努力し
続けてるプロセスです。是非ね、頑張って
ください。コメント欄に何か気づいたこと
あったらコメントしてください。そして
チャンネル登録、まだの方は是非
チャンネル登録してください。また次回の
YouTubeでお控えましょう。感謝し
ます。ありがとう。ありがとうございます
。
決して負けない経営だ。まず経営者自身が
お金よりも仕事の内容そのものに惚れ込ん
でるかどうかなです。